So you're dating, I assume you're dating.
I don't know if you're in a relationship.
But there's got to be a difference between English guys and American guys, right?
Yeah, there's definitely one or two differences that I've noticed.
English guys are very well put together and they dress really well...
...and they're very well-mannered.
But they're also very restrained usually in the whole courting situation.
I'm used to being first of all, ignored for like the first two months of the ritual.
And then, maybe they'll acknowledge my presence.
And then, they'll probably be a little mean to me and then, maybe well, whatever.
And then, I arrive in America!
I remember few nights into Brown, this guy's just being like,...
..."I like you, you're great. Let's go out on a date; let's do it."...
...and I'm like, "I'm sorry, what just happened?"
This is a huge culture shock for me,...
...it's that they're very open and very straightforward.
But they wear flip-flops...
...so I don't know if I like that.
You gotta figure it out.
It's hard.